Yo les voy a hablar hoy
de una enfermedad fantástica.
Le digo fantástica porque no existe
este término en el diccionario.
Esta enfermedad se llama la broncemia
y dicen que los médicos que la padecen,
ya que broncemia etimológicamente sería
la cantidad de nivel de bronce en sangre,
los médicos que la padecen,
a medida que pasan los años
al comenzar a invadirse con bronce,
creen que son próceres y sueñan
con que su estatua de bronce
alguna vez esté en el patio del hospital
o de la clínica en la que él trabajó.
Este término los escuché
hace fácilmente 30 años
del doctor Feijóo Osorio,
un médico reconocido cordobés
en un servicio de cirugía
del Hospital de Clínicas
acá en Córdoba,
en el cual era también profesor
adjunto Narciso Hernández;
porque muchos atribuyen
a Narciso Hernández
este término de broncemia;
pero desde que la encontré
la utilicé en la docencia
y me quedó grabada
esa palabra para siempre.
Decía Narciso Hernández que el enfermo
de broncemia pasaba por 2 etapas.
La primera etapa era la importantitis,
en la que él se creía que era
tan importante que nadie era mejor que él.
La segunda etapa era la inmortalitis.
Cuando el paciente ya
llegaba a su etapa final
y cuando el bronce
invadía todo su cuerpo,
ahí sí se creía que era una
estatua olímpica e inmortal.
¿Dónde se desarrolla esta enfermedad?
Y generalmente en aquellos lugares que
presumen de un alto nivel
de intelectualidad
y el medio ecológico ideal sin ninguna
duda es la universidad;
pero también se han descrito
casos muy severos
en tribunales, grandes sanatorios,
en sociedades científicas, en empresas,
también en instituciones
deportivas de renombre
y por qué no decirlo,
ayer en el almuerzo me comentaban,
también en la clase política.
Y justamente en la clase política
parece que sin antecedentes
que lo hicieran presumir,
la soberbia y la solemnidad
propia del broncémico
aparecen en el político
de manera espontánea.
Otro dato importante es la edad.
Generalmente comienza a aparecer
a los 45, 55 años
pero los casos más severos se presentan
entre los cincuenta y cinco
a los 65 años;
que es cuando el hombre
en su deseo de disertar
y hablar de cosas
que generalmente ha leído
de forma bastante superficial,
está en relación inversa con su edad
y su capacidad de poder
comprender y discernir.
El sexo también es importante,
se creía que era más que nada
del sexo masculino;
pero creo que ahora
con el auge del feminismo
si hiciéramos nuevas
estadísticas bien concretas
encontraríamos gran número
de mujeres con broncemia.
Y lo que todos los autores
están de acuerdo en asegurar
es que la broncemia en las mujeres
siempre ha sido caso de extrema
gravedad y prácticamente incurable.
(Risas)
Los síntomas más comunes
del broncémico son 3:
la diarrea mental,
(Risas)
la hipoacusia interlocutoria
y el reflejo cefalocaudal.
La diarrea mental se caracteriza
por una verborragia exagerada
en la que el broncémico habla y habla
todo lo que su cerebro depone.
Generalmente habla erguido
y como si estuviera hablando
desde un púlpito, arriba de un atrio.
La sordera interlocutoria acompaña
siempre la diarrea mental.
Cuando el broncémico
habla y habla y habla
sus oídos no escuchan nada.
Cuando el broncémico habla,
no escucha a nadie.
Y el reflejo cefalocaudal
es el que le da esa forma
tan característica de caminar
con la cabeza elevada, la cola parada
por la impregnación de bronce
y algunos autores dicen que
el bronce comienza a depositarse
primero en los pies
y después sube hasta
llegar al cerebro;
y si esto fuera cierto,
posiblemente justifique el hecho
de que los broncémicos desde
el comienzo de su enfermedad
ya no caminan,
se desplazan majestuosamente.
(Risas)
Esto de la broncemia que pensaba
que era una cosa actual
no es así.
Les voy a contar.
1500 años antes de Cristo
cuando se realiza en la antigua India
la separación de las castas sociales
en 5 castas,
la quinta casta era la de los intocables.
Aquellos que no tenían derecho a nada,
ni siquiera tenían derecho
a la atención médica.
La cuarta casta
era de los trabajadores inferiores,
la tercera casta de los comerciantes
y la segunda casta
era la casta de los anvastas
a la que pertenecían los médicos
y la primera casta, la de los reyes.
Estas 2
la primera y la segunda castas
decían que descendían de los dioses.
Pienso que tal vez alguno
de estos médicos broncémicos
creen realmente que
descienden de los dioses.
Pronto en la historia de la medicina
también todos oyeron hablar de Galeno.
Galeno de Pérgamo era un médico
que ejerció en la Roma imperial
en el año 162 y era un broncémico,
un ególatra incorregible.
Hablaba permanentemente
de sus grandes ganancias,
de su fama, este y revestía todas
sus curaciones de una manera milagrosa
como para poder
impresionar más a la gente.
Pero en la época actual, ahora,
estoy seguro que cualquiera de nosotros
en el lugar donde desarrollemos
nuestra actividad
y cualquiera sea ella,
estoy seguro que debemos
convivir con broncémicos.
Y quisiera darles un dato que
sé que es muy preciso y precoz.
Muchos autores dicen que
uno de los primeros síntomas
que tiene el broncémico
es que comienza a perder
la capacidad de sonreir.
No voy a seguir hablando
de los síntomas del broncémico
pero creo que es importante
en esta charla decir
qué podemos hacer para que
nuestros joven médicos
o para que los jóvenes
no se contagien de broncemia.
Yo creo que únicamente podemos hacer
con todos nuestros esfuerzos
tratar de imbuirles en sus cerebros,
en sus mentes,
el deseo de ayudar a sus colegas,
a sus colaboradores,
a sus pacientes.
De sembrar dentro de ellos
para que florezca
el espíritu de servicio.
Y quiero distinguir entre servicio
y espíritu de servicio.
Recuerdo hace muchos años
cuando estaba haciendo mi tesis doctoral
en la sala de cirugía experimental,
vi un conejo que le sacaba a otro conejo
los hilos de sutura del lomo.
Lo habíamos operado,
una cirugía en el lomo.
Esto, de sacarle los puntos
un animal a otro,
no es extraño en la escala animal.
Incluso animales
de distintas especies
se sacan las espinas
o los cuerpos extraños.
Lo que este conejo estaba
haciendo en ese momento,
le estaba haciendo
al otro un servicio.
Porque el servicio es eso, un acto;
que puede ser instintivo
y no necesitar la razón.
En cambio el espíritu de servicio
es el profundo deseo de satisfacer
a aquellos que necesitan de nosotros.
No es un acto, es una actitud,
es una función de vida.
Si los médicos jóvenes
no se preparan para nutrirse
intensamente del espíritu de servicio,
están preparándose para
contagiarse de broncemia.
Hablábamos sí,
del espíritu de servicio,
la forma de inculcarlo,
pero esas cosas yo no puedo ordenarle
a mis médicos jóvenes por decreto.
No le puedo decir,
a partir de mañana piensen así
a partir de mañana comiencen
a querer a sus pacientes.
Eso no es posible,
pero sí podemos ayudarlos
con el ejemplo cotidiano
para que esto pueda prender
dentro de sus corazones,
dentro de sus deseos imperiosos
de ayudar a sus colegas,
a sus pacientes.
Les voy a contar un cuento
para que les quede.
Hay un famoso pintor
que había presentado una
exposición que se llamaba
"Las puertas del corazón".
Eran puertas de distintos colores.
La exposición era un éxito,
puertas hermosas, colores combinados;
pero había un personaje dentro de la sala
que se paraba dentro de cada puerta,
la miraba y pasaba a la otra.
De pronto se para delante de una.
Justo al lado de él está el pintor.
Entonces, humildemente le dice:
"Vea, discúlpeme,
las puertas que Ud. pinta son hermosas
pero yo soy cerrajero y quiero
darle mi modesta opinión.
Veo que sus puertas no tienen picaporte,
¿cómo se van a abrir?"
Y el pintor le dice:
"Mire, lo he pensado muchos años
pero las puertas del corazón no
tienen picaporte del lado de afuera
porque solo se abren
del lado de adentro.
Estoy seguro que
Uds. han compartido
con médicos broncémicos
y me imagino que cualquiera
de Uds. podría subir acá y contarnos
cómo fue su experiencia
al lado de un broncémico
de cualquier profesión.
Yo les voy a contar lo que
le pidieron a Bernie
si es que él es un pionero
de la medicina mente-cuerpo
3 enfermos terminales
jóvenes que murieron
pocos días después
cuando Bernie les dijo:
"¿Qué quieren que le diga
a los médicos jóvenes
porque yo tengo
que hablar ahora
en el acto de egreso?
¿Qué mensaje quieren que transmita?"
Estos pacientes le dijeron:
"que golpeen en nuestra
habitación antes de entrar,
que cuando salgan
se despidan y nos saluden
y que cuando hablen con nosotros
nos miren a los ojos".
Ninguno de estos pidió
que encontraran la cura
de su enfermedad,
solo pedían respeto,
solo querían respeto.
Y termino esta charla
con ese impasse
propio de la edad.
Les voy a contar
una anécdota verídica.
Es en una sala de operaciones,
una larga cirugía.
Una cirugía prolongada que
de pronto deben reemplazar
a una de las enfermeras
y cuando esta se retira
pasa por detrás del cirujano,
un hombre que era reconocido
por su espíritu de servicio.
Pasa detrás de él,
le acaricia la espalda,
le da un beso y sale.
Eso fue para este médico
un regalo hermoso.
Un hermoso regalo porque esto
incluía todo el dolor y el amor
que habían sentido
médico y enfermera juntos,
que habían compartido
en la sala de operaciones.
Esto le dio fuerzas
al médico para seguir
y como diría otro
cirujano amigo mío:
"a ese cirujano se le llenó
el corazón de música".
Los médicos dioses
esos médicos
que desayunan con Dios
y después bajan
a atender a sus pacientes
estos médicos broncémicos
o los broncémicos
de cualquier actividad,
de cualquier nivel sociocultural,
no pueden recibir regalos así
porque se sienten tan por encima
de todos los que están a su lado
que son incapaces
de compartir nada.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)